there's a lot of people that look up to
you like they're inspired by you because
you've taken a kind of non-linear path
through life is there any advice you
have for people
like in high school today
that are trying to figure out what they
want to do do they want to go to
stanford do they want to pursue a career
um
in i don't know uh in industry or
or go kind of the path you guys have
taken which is have the ability to do
all of that and still choose to make the
thing that you're passionate about your
your life
i always like the calculated risks
approach where
when you're younger it's okay to take
more risks because you have a lot more
time
but there has to be a reason why you're
doing that particular risk is it
something that you've spent a lot of
time already really passionate and
working on or is it just something
that's trendy and you want to do it
because you don't have a better option
and that's actually similar to what
andrea did when she decided to go into
streaming instead of school
yeah it was the reason i got into
streaming because i was initially going
to go to college but the pandemics it
was right the beginning of the pandemic
and all my classes were online and i
never thought ever since i was 12 like
my dream was school and i saw myself
nowhere else than going to university
and i just i thought of it and kind of
weighed out the wrist i'm like well if i
take a gap year and i try streaming with
my sister
what do i have to lose i gained some
experience working with someone who has
a lot more experience than i do um and
then i can go back to school after
um and if i go to school right now i do
online classes for a year and that's
something that i could do at any time so
that's why it made a lot of sense for me
to go into this
but of course this is also a very unique
opportunity so i don't know how
applicable but i do think overall the
calculated risk is a really good
solution
is like chess
exactly maybe sometimes exactly
you